hello my name is Kara Vasa from layer we
augmented reality platform and we are
technology para near this year in
answering a question of thunder group on
innovation what are you doing
specifically to invest in innovation and
job creation I found a really
interesting question and actually we add
layer belief that augmented reality is
the next mass media actual method
reality is overlaying a layer of digital
information or experiences object on top
of reality and currently that's going
through the mobile phones as a looking
glass you can imagine that in a few
years time you'll actually be wearing
glasses and be fully immersed into a
world when a digital world and the
physical reality become one um this is a
mass medium and it's growing extremely
fast and layer is actually taking a very
important position in at least we think
and in creating an entire ecosystem and
currently we have already created a lot
of jobs not only inside of our own
company is growing really fast within
the entire ecosystem which are creating
layers help mentality experiences for
themselves and for third parties
actually there are already about 50
companies globally specialized in
creating such experiences and making
money with us and see that that's
growing very quickly um so there's a
whole new ecosystem and a whole new type
of work actually being being created
here in this mouse wheel and we're only
getting started we only end of a very
early stage of the development of this
medium you can compare today with the
1994 of the internet where
come to such as Amazon Google Twitter
still had to be invented or the stage
where actually radio became TV and the
first TV shows were still just a radio
show with the playing a image behind it
and formats such as reality TV or
American Idol or TV commercial so had to
be invented so we can imagine that this
is a whole new industry which will be
growing very very fast in the coming
years and yeah I think that's also our
contribute contribution to well to
innovation and job creation that we
stimulate the creation of this whole
ecosystem and also new jobs